Többek között Anna megkérdezte, hogy
mikor megy a következő anyjához.
>> Ühüm.
>> Tehát ez ennyire ez a szülői fogalom és
ez az anyai fogalom és a család.
>> És akkor mit mondtál?
>> Mondtam, hogy te most megérkeztél a te
családodban. Ez a te családod. Én a te
anyád vagyok. Mármint, hogy nem ő az én
lányom, hanem én vagyok az ő anyja.
>> Hm.
Ez ez a te otthonod
itt. Te itthon vagy.
Aki bizonytalan, annak bizonyosság kell.
>> Köszöntök minden kedves hallgatót a
Navigator podcastnek az újabb
epizódjában.
Egy nagyon izgalmas témát hoztam. Az
örök befogadásról fogok beszélgetni Gál
Ildikóval és ez egy kemény téma lesz
Ildikó. Úgyhogy már alig várom, hogy
bele belevágjunk ebbe a témába, de
először is üdvözöllek a műsorban.
>> Köszönöm a meghívást, köszönöm, hogy itt
lehetek. És valóban ez egy érdekes téma,
de talán csak azért, mert keveset
beszélünk róla.
>> Keveset beszélünk róla, és te vagy az
első, aki ilyen közeli vagy számomra, és
a az életedben látom azt, hogy mit
jelent az örökbefogadás. Ugyanis
örökbefogadtál egy kislányt ezelőtt
nyolc évvel körülbelül.
>> Hét év lesz most februárban.
>> Hét év lesz most.
És nagyon-nagyon érdekelnének a
részletek ezzel kapcsolatban.
Az első kérdésem viszont inkább arra
vonatkozna, hogy 17 évig dolgoztál a
gyermekvédelemben, és az, aki nem tudja,
hogy ez mivel jár, nekünk meséltél egy
pár dolgot már így.
Röviden be tudnád mutatni, később aztán
biztos vagyok benne, hogy példákat is
hozol ebből, de be tudnád mutatni ennek
a 17 évnek a a mélységét, intenzitását?
Milyen volt ott dolgozni? Úgy gondolom,
hogy amikor emberekkel dolgozunk és
különösen gyerekekkel,
ugyanannyira életekkel foglalkozunk,
mint például egy orvos a műtőasztalon.
Ha szigorúan vesszük, akkor igazából
szinte agyműtétek történnek, hogyha a
terápiákra gondolunk, merthogy teljesen
átkonfiguráljuk azt, ami történik. Ez
hihetetlen felelősség, főleg, hogyha az
eszközök végesek.
Nekem nagyon segített az az attitűd,
hogy
igazából azt észrevenni, hogy mire van
szüksége egy gyereknek. Most ha azt
mondom, hogy 17 évig a gyermekvédelemnél
dolgoztam, és bántalmazás területén,
akkor mindenki mindenféle bántalmazásra
tud gondolni. De képzeljünk el például
egy olyan helyzetet, ahol egy gyerek egy
nagyon súlyosan pszichés, beteg
felnőttel élt együtt, és természetesen
ez a felnőtt nem akarja bándalmazni a
gyerekét, de nem képes felnevelni. A
másik felnőtt meg ebből ki van lépve a
másik szülő. Elméletileg ezt az esetet
nekünk nem kell felvenni, mert hát
nem bántalmazzák a gyereket. Azzal jött
az édesanya, hogy a gyerek bántalmazza
őt. Én meg azt mondtam, nem lehet így
élni. Fel kell venni az apával a
kapcsolatot. Annak idején egyedül
vállaltam az esetet. Azt mondtam, senki
nem kell segítség.
Felvettük az édesapával a kapcsolatot,
hazajött külföldről,
és onnan kezdve a kislány az apával élt.
Nem akarok látványos esetekről mesélni,
majd csak egy-egy helyzetbe, hogy
megértsük a súlyosságát bizonyos
dolgoknak. De azt hiszem, hogy ez az
attitűd, hogy ott kell lenni azért az
emberért, akinek szüksége van
segítségre, nem azt nézni, hogy
beletalál-e a kategóriába.
Én ezzel próbáltam dolgozni.
Természetesen megvan az áram kimerültem,
amint te is tudsz róla. Váltanom
kellett, hogy az életemet élhessem. És
anya lehessek.
>> És anya lehess. Igen. Akkor akkor
szerintem vágjunk is bele a témába, hogy
és aztán majd visszatérhetünk majd
bizonyos epizódokra.
Miért döntöttél úgy, hogy örökbe fogsz
fogadni?
>> Azért érdekes számomra a kérdés, mertogy
nagyon-nagyon régre kell visszanyúlni.
Igazából mindig is a szívemnek a vágya
volt, meg hogy valahogy mindig bennem
volt.
Nem akarok az előre meghatározó sorsról
beszélni, de valahogy minél jobban
öregszem, úgy látok egy vonalat, ami
megvan az életünkben, és valahogy ha
azon megyünk, akkor biztonságban
vagyunk. Én tínédzser korom óta arról
álmodoztam, hogy nem volt így
megfogalmazva, hogy örök befogadás, de
hogy én majd gyerekeket fogok nevelni a
saját gyermekeimet meg a másét, de hogy
igazából mindenki a saját gyermekem,
talán egy álomhoz térnék vissza. Volt
nekem egy álmom, éjszaka álmodtam ezt az
álmot.
sétáltam egy erdőbe. Nyolc-kilenc gyerek
volt körülöttem,
körülbelül egykorúak voltak álomban. És
hogy ezek mind az én gyermekeim voltak.
Ezek közül egynek adtam én életet
álomba, de mind az enyém volt. És amikor
körülnéztem valahogy sose láttam, hogy
hol van az a gyerek, akit én szültem,
hanem mind az enyém volt. És azt hiszem,
hogy ez benne volt a pakliba. Aztán
fiatal felnőtt lettem, másképp láttam az
életet, más modelleket láttam, valahogy
elfelejtődött ez a történet, de utána
újra előjött. És
valahogy amikor a családra gondoltam,
mindig arra gondoltam, hogy nekem
lesznek természetes gyerekeim és lesznek
örökbe fogadott gyerekeim.
>> És akkor megszületett benned ez a vágy,
hogy szeretnél örökbe fogadni.
Hogy indul el valaki, hogy örökbe
fogadjon? Én most személy szerint elég
sok embert ismerek a környezetemben,
akik pont ugyanennél a lépésnél vannak.
ez a vágy úgy érlelődik forma a
szívükbe, de fogalmak sincs, hogy hogyan
kell ennek neki fogni.
Ö
>> egy nagyon erős kihívással hasonlítanám
össze. Tehát amikor az az érzésünk, hogy
néha a kihívás nagyobb, mint a
képességeink, és akkor az segít
igazából, ha egy célt megfogalmazunk és
lépéseket látunk magunk előtt, és akkor
elindulunk. Az, hogy elindulok egy úton,
nem azt jelenti, hogy végigjárom az
utat, csak az, hogy megnézem, hogy nekem
való-e.
>> Tehát mindig egy lépést tegyünk előre.
>> Mindig egy lépést előre. És amikor már
nem kényelmes a lépés, vagy megálluk,
vagy visszafordulhatok, igazából az,
hogy megteszem az első lépést, és
mindjárt mondom, hogy mi az, az nem
jelenti azt, hogy elköteleződtem a
folyamat iránt, csak leveszi a
feszültséget rólunk. És akkor én ezt
ajánlom, hogy ezzel az első lépéssel
kezdje el mindenki. Keresse fel a
gyermekvédelmi igazgatóságot,
ami románul úgy hangzik, hogy direkcia
de assistence sociál protekció pilloli.
Ez minden megyeözpontban van. azért
mondtam el románul, mert hogy ezt tudjuk
használni itt Erdélyben.
És megkeresni az adopciós irodát. Lehet,
hogy érdemes betelefonálni, egy
időpontot
kérni, merthogy az első lépés az egy
információs találkozó. Tehát valakivel
találkozunk, az az illető szakember
elmondja a pontos lépéseket, a
követelményeket, mit jelent az örök
befogadás, hova kell tovább menni.
És onnan kezdve az az információs
alkalom után egy
hát végül is egy találkozási papírt
írunk alá, amiben pont ez van, hogy
tudom már, hogy mit jelent ez a
folyamat, ha, gondolkodom, ameddig
akarok. Mondjuk most nem öt év múlva
kell visszajönni, hogyha eldöntöttem, de
van gondolkodási időm, akár hónapok, és
ha eldöntöttem, hogy szeretném, akkor
beléphetek a következő
lépést követem, kérvényt leadok,
összegyűjtöm az iratokat. Természetesen
az iratok
onnan elkezdve, hogy erkölcsileg
leellenőrzik
az életemet. ilyenkor egy átvilágítás
történik,
>> egy teljes körű átvilágítás, tehát az
egészségem, a szociális helyzetem, a
családi helyzetünk, szociális ankétot
készítenek, pszichológiai felméréseket
végeznek és ez a felmérési időszak három
hónapig tart. Attól kezdve, hogy leadtam
a kérvényt, rá három hónapra, vagy
elfogadnak, vagy elutasítanak annak
függvényében, hogy ők mit látnak bennem.
>> Mi mi az, ami anyagi szempontból
követelménye? Kell kell kell rendelkezé
például stabil jövedelemmel gondolom
lakással, ah aki örökbe fogad.
>> Bizony stabilitásra szükség van, de nem
kell saját lakás legyen, tehát
albérletbe és simán örökbe lehet
fogadni. Tehát azt az kell legyen, hogy
hogy
valamilyen szinten garanciát tudjak
vállalni arra, hogy a gyermek megfelelő
körülmények között fog élni.
Nincs egy jövedelmi alsó vagy felső
határ.
>> És az, hogy például párkapcsolatban
éljen az a személy, hogy legyen egy
férfi is és egy nő is a a háttérben, ez
követelmény. Vagyis hogy nyilván most
nem, mert a te esetedben nem így van, de
egy kicsit kibontá.
>> Nálunk nem. Magyarországon igen. Ez
követelmény, hogy egy házasság legyen,
és egy férfi és egy nő, egy egyedülálló
személy nem fogadhat örökben. Nálunk egy
egyedülálló személy örökbe fogadhat. Egy
férfi is örökbe fogadhat, vagy csak
>> egy férfi is örökbe fogadhat.
>> És igazából ezek előítéletek, tehát egy
férfi ugyanúgy tud vigyázni a gyerekére.
>> Ez abszolút előítéletből jött [nevetés]
az én részemről, azt tényleg bevallom.
Igen.
>> Tehát egy férfi tökéletesen képes
szülőnek lenni és és ugyanúgy örökbe,
tehát szülő kell legyen. Én én nem
szerintem ez egy mesterséges határ, hogy
ez egy természetes szülő vagy egy
örökbefogadó szülő.
>> Ühüm.
>> Szülők leszünk.
>> Vá. Azzá válunk.
Azzá válunk, amikor van egy gyerekünk.
>> Azzá válunk. És az arról van valamilyen
statisztika, hogy körülbelül hány
gyermek vár arra, hogy örökbe fogadják,
és hányan állnak sorba, hogy örökbe
fogadjanak gyermekeket.
>> Egész biztos, hogy van statisztika, de
ez nem hozzáférhető az átlagpopuláció
számára. Tehát ez az intézmények keretén
belül vannak. Tehát lehet tudni, hogy
hány gyereket fogadtak örökbe a tavaly
vagy tavaly előtt, hány szülő nyújtotta
be, hány felnőtt nyújtotta be az igényét
arra, hogy szülővé váljon.
De ez nem egy olyan, tehát hogy
rákeresek például a bukaresti
gyermekvédelmi osztály
oldalára, és akkor kiderül, hogy hány
gyereket fogadtak örökbe, hány vár
örökbefogadásra, és hányan szeretnének
örökbe fogadni. Sajnos nem.
Azt hiszem, hogy akkor a legjobb módszer
az lenne, hogyha végigmennénk ezen a
folyamaton, hogy ha a te példádat
vennénk alapul, hogy te hogyan mentél
végig, hogyan hogyan érezted magad
közben a folyamat közben. Következő
kérdésem az lenne, hogy miután
valószínűleg aláírtad ezt a papírt,
amivel informálódtál,
gondolom, hogy akkor hazamentél és
érlelted magadban ezt a döntést, és
utána pedig akkor jelezted, hogy készen
állsz arra, hogy és átvilágítottak, és
akkor akkor elindult a folyamat. Mi a
következő lépés? És számodra mi volt a
következő lépés?
>> A következő lépés, miután ezen túl
vagyunk, hogyha a formaira
reflektálunk most és utána beszélhetünk
szubjektíven, hogy mit jelentett
számomra.
Miután megkaptam ezt a jóváhagyást, hogy
örökbe fogadhatok, onnan kezdve
elkezdenek olyan gyereket keresni, ami
nekem megfelel azon kritériumok szerint,
amik meg vannak állapítva.
>> Tudnánk egy kicsit a kritériumokról
beszélni? Milyen kritériumokat tudsz
ilyenkor megállítani?
>> Ezt akartam most mondani, hogy egyrészt
ők állapítanak meg egy lelki profilt,
egy pszichológiai profilt, amiben amik
az én erősségeim, illetve a
gyermekeiknek is van egy ilyen profil,
hogy mire van szükségük. Tehát, hogy
milyen szülőre van szükségük, hogy
fejlődni tudjanak, és a szülőknek, hogy
mik az erősségeik.
Ez az, amit megállapítanak a
szakemberek. Illetve van egy olyan lap,
amelyiket én töltök ki. arra vonatkozom,
hogy mit tudok vállalni. Tehát például,
hogy tudok-e vállalni egy olyan
gyereket, akinek esetleg egy fizikai
fogyatékossága van, vagy tudok-e
vállalni egy olyan gyereket, akiről
tudom, hogy vérfertőzésből született,
vagy tudok-e vállalni egy olyan
gyereket, aki nem lát, vagy krónikus
betegségi állapota van, de ö de nem
életveszélyes.
Ilyenkor bőrszín alapján is lehet
választani például, hogy hogy azt
mondod, hogy nem szeretném, hogy fehér
legyen. Most nyilván ez nagyon-nagyon
durván hangzik ez, de el tudom képzelni,
hogy egy szülőpont erre gondol, hogy
>> hát ez ezt egyfajta kiszűrése van ennek
igazából kiköthetem, hogy nem szeretnék
róma gyereket.
>> Ühüm.
>> Meg meghatározhatóm a gyereknek, sőt ezt
kérik is, az életkorát, mármint nem,
hogy két évest szeretnék, hanem milyen
életkorok között? Tehát például nekem
nullától öt évig volt az első gyerekre,
és talán ide tenném hozzá, hogy ne
legyen olyan mesterséges, mert biztos
bele fogunk csúszni ebbe, hogy én egy
most egy másik folyamatban vagyok. Most
másodjára, mivel fiatalodtam időközben,
most kettő-től öt évig állapítottam meg
a gyerek életkorát. A nemre vonatkozóan
nem zártam ki egyik nemest, tehát lehet
kislány és kisfiú, és először is így
döntöttem, másodszor is így döntöttem.
De kiköthetem, hogy nem szeretnék roma
gyereket. És akkor ebben benne van a
bőrszínének a megszűrése igazából.
>> A másik az az, hogy lehet a gyerek
elméletileg vagy az én meglátásomban
Róma, de ha a szülők például románoknak
vagy magyaroknak vallották magukat,
akkor ez van beírva.
>> És akkor csak én lehet szembesülök
azzal, hogy lehet feketébb, mint
amilyennek szeretném. Bár érdemes
megmérni, hogy igazából egy boldog
vidám, intelligens gyereket szeretnék,
vagy kizárnám bőrszín alapján, hogy egy
ilyen legyen.
>> Tehát ki az, aki nem szeretne egy boldog
vidámi, intelligens gyermeket?
>> Hát talán az, aki
a bőrszínt helyezi előnybe, [nevetés]
mertogy ezzel kizárhatjuk.
>> Hm.
Amúgy emlékszem, hogy amikor hallgattam
ilyen mindenféle pszichológiai
képzéseket Amerikából, az egyik példának
pont Romániát hozták fel, hogy a
kommunizmus után azok az állapotok, amik
uralkodtak az árvaházakban, az egy olyan
sok volt a világ számára. Tehát a sajtó
kijött és filmeztek kicsit olyan
hangulaton volt, mintogyha ilyen második
Auschwitz
féle ilyen ilyen feltárás történt volna.
borzasztó dolgok voltak, és
lehet, hogy ez a fajta árvaház hangulat
szűrődik át a a az az átlag embernek,
ahogy nekem is, hogy most is olyan
árvaházak vannak, de de most hol vannak
amúgy ezek a a gyermekek? Ezek a
tradicionális árvaházak tudtom
megszűntek.
>> Megszűntek teljes mértékben. Tehát most
már nem csak, hogy nincs, merthogy azok
tényleg ilyen Ausvic hangolatú árvaházak
voltak minden tekintetben.
Azonban most ilyen
mindenféle szociális otthonok vannak,
vagy olyanok, ahol
házaspárok vannak, arra alkalmazva, hogy
szociális szülők legyenek.
vagy másfajta ilyen elhelyezésbe levő
gyerekek, ahol váltásba jön mondjuk a
személyzet, nevelők meg pszichológus,
meg szOcmás, viszont meg van határozva
mindig a szám nagyon 14 fölé nem mehet.
Ezenkívül vannak a nevelőszülők,
talán ha a román kifejezést is
használjuk, az assistent maternál, ahol
a saját otthonába valaki fizetést kap és
gyereket nevel, de egyet kettőt kaphat,
tehát egy-két gyermeket nevel a saját
családja mellett teljesen családi
környezetbe. És akkor ez már teljesen
családi ízű.
És akkor akkor bármikor elvehetik ezeket
a tehát hogyha a saját családodba
befogadsz egy vagy két gyermeket, akkor
egy-két három pár év múlva bárki
elveheti.
>> Hát az a gyerek intézményben van
elméletileg, hogyha én nevelőszülő
vagyok. Tehát ez egy intézmény.
>> Ez egy intézmény.
>> Igen. Tehát ez nem egy örök befogadás,
ez nem egy elhelyezés. a placamen
például a saját testvérem gyermekeit, ha
ő valamiért nem tudja eltartani többet,
őket, mit tudom én, isten őriz,
balesetet szenvedett, akkor a gyerekek
jöhetnek hozzám lakni, és ez egy
elhelyezés, és akkor ha nem bántom a
gyerekeket tőlem, nem vihetik el őket.
Most nyilván ez jobb, mint az a az
ausvici körülmény, de valahol egyből
megszólal bennem, hogy ez az a gyermek,
amikor egy ennyire személyes
környezetben egy egy családnak a része,
akkor onnan kiszakítani ez valahol
kegyetlenségnek tűnik.
>> Hát ezért vannak azok a tréningek,
amikben meg kell tartani azt a keretet.
Tehát a gyereknek mindig tudnia kell,
hogy ez nem az ő családja. Ez egy olyan
család, akivel nevelkedik, jó esetben
érintkezik a természetes családjával.
Tehát amúgy is tudja, hogy van ott egy,
tehát ez nem egy örök befogadás. Ő akkor
még a szülő anyjával, szülő apjával,
testszerinti testvéreivel tarthatja a
kapcsolatot, ha látogatják.
>> Tart kapot.
>> Tehát akkor amúgy is ez van. Illetve
nekem mindig ez volt, mert ugye én
nevelőszülőkkel is foglalkoztam, akik
bántalmazott gyerekek voltak elhelyezve.
Ez mindig kikötés, hogy nem szabad
anyának, apának szólítsák őket a
gyerekek, mert amikor onnan elszakad,
akkor elvesztett egy anyát és egy apát,
illetve romlik az anya és apa fogalom.
Tehát szólítson a neveden, szólítson
Kokónak, Momónak, bárminek
egy beceneven, egy cuk, vagy bármi
másnak, de nem szólíthat anyának meg
apának. Persze ezt sokszor nem tartják
be. Szerintem még most se,
de ez a szabály, illetve a gyerekek
amúgy is tudják, mert megértik, hogy
bejön valaki a lakásba, ellenőrzik a
körülményeket, megnézik a ruhatárát, ne
legyen szakadt, ne legyen romlott, ne
legyen. Tehát érzik, amit nem érez egy
természetes családban felnővő gyerek,
hogy majd valahonnan kintről beérkezik
valaki a lakásunkba, és egy kicsit
körülnéz. Persze nem durván, nem
investigatívan, de azért mégis belenéz a
szekrénybe, ugye?
>> Tehát ezt érz hol van például a Böyte
Csabának az intézményei? Hol
helyezkednek el? Mert én egyik egyik
alkalommal meglátogattam, és ott tényleg
több mint 100 gyermek volt. Tehát, hogy
ez így ilyen tradicionális amúgy nagyon
jó körülmények voltak le a kalappal. Én
nem jobb körülményekben nőttek fel azok
a gyerekek, mint én a amikor gyermek
voltam. Hogy ha megszűntek ezek a nagy
árvaházak, akkor mégis hogy lehetséges,
hogy hogy Böjte Csabának lehetnek ilyen
intézmények?
>> Nem tudok hozzászólni. Nem szeretnék
válaszolni a kérdésre, mert nem tudom,
hogy mi a státos. Tehát egy másik
megyében van mind, ahol én dolgoztam.
Ezeknek különböző volt a a határideje,
amíg ez felszámolódott. Nem is tudom,
hogy ő most milyen körülmények között,
mert
>> szóval térjünk vissza akkor a te
esetedre.
leadtad a követelménylistát, hogyha
csúnyán akarnék fogalmazni, és elkezdtek
keresni számodra
potenciális gyermeket.
Ilyenkor mennyi idő, mennyi idő volt
neked, ameddig találtak? És több jelölt
is volt, vagy vagy egyből már elérkeztél
Annához?
>> Hát külön választjuk a két folyamatot,
mert időközben változott a törvény. Most
jelenleg, és akkor ezt hangsúlyozom ki,
és utána beszélek az szubjektív
állapotról. Most az van, hogy hat
hónapig az azon megye keretén belül
keresnek gyereket, ahol lakom és ahol
felmértek. Ha lejárt a hat hónap, akkor
ország szintjén keresik. Ez, hogy örökbe
fogadhatok, ez az irat, ez a jóváhagyás,
ez öt évre szól. Öt év után kell
felújítani, hogyha nem sikerült addig
örökbefogadni.
Visszatérve a két külön örökbefogadási
folyamatomra,
én Annát körülbelül egy év után kaptam
meg. Ő volt az első.
Teljesen nyitott szívvel mentem oda. Azt
hiszem, nem kell elmondjam, hogy
természetesen szorongás volt bennem.
meggondolkodtam, honnan fogom tudni,
hogy ő az én lányom vagy
bármi. Ö talán szubjektív oldalába
beletartozik az is, hogy
mikor közölték velem, hogy van egy
kislány, akét meglátogathatok és
megnézhetem, hogy az én kislányom
lesz-e, akkor nekem megint egy álmom
volt, és akkor álmodtam, hogy Annának
fogják hívni.
Tehát ez nem egy választás volt, hogy
illetve választás volt, hogy ráállok
erre a
erre az álomra, de hogy ettől eltekintve
én egy racionális
ember vagyok, ezért nagyon figyelmesen
mentem. Meglátogattam a kislányt,
megmondták, hogy akkor még csak
ismerkedésről van szó. A kislány nem
tudja, hogy egy potenciális szülő jön
hozzá.
játszottunk együtt, beszélgettünk és
minden alkalommal, amikor és utána az
első találkozás után el kell dönteni,
hogy folytatod-e a találtatást. Anna
esetében szinte rögtön megírhattam volna
a papírt, hogy szeretném folytatni.
Enyhén el volt hanyagolva
kognitív szempontból. Tehát láttam, hogy
több van a gyermekbe potenciál, mint
amennyi, de nem tudtam akkor, hogy
mennyire értelmes.
Azt mondtam, hogy fejleszthető.
Jól kapcsolódtunk,
egyelőre nem találok semmi olyasmit, ami
gát lehet a kapcsolatban, és akkor
menjünk tovább. Pont úgy, mint az
udvarlásnál. Tehát nem történt olyan,
ami miatt törésre mehetett volna. Talán
a helyzetnek az érdekessége az az, hogy
én ebben a percbe abszolút csodálatosnak
és gyönyörűnek látom a lányomat, de
akkor hála Istennek most mondom, nem
láttam szép gyereknek, és nem vitte el
az esztétikai rész a gondolataimat.
Tehát effektív csak a kapcsolatra,
a dialógusra az együttlétre tudtam
koncentrálni, és az nagyon jól ment
közöttünk. Tehát összehangolódtunk,
tudtunk együtt játszani, figyeltünk
egymásra. Így
minden alkalom ugyanígy épült fel.
Megnéztük, hogy hogyan tudunk egymáshoz
viszonyulni. De mielőtt amúgy
találkoztál vele, előtte láttál egy
fényképet róla? Ö
>> két fényképet láttam róla. A két fénykép
úgy nézett ki, mintha két külön gyermek
lett volna. [nevetés]
És mind a kettő különbözött attól, amit
láttam, amikor találkozna.
Nem akart megállni, hogy lefényképezzék,
és akkor
ahonnan fényképezték, onnan. De igen,
mutatnak fényképet és bemutatják a
családot. Tehát amikor szólnak, hogy van
egy gyerek, akkor fényképet mutatnak,
bemutatják a családi helyzetét, hogy mi
a mi az, amivel jön ez a gyerek, mikor
született, milyen, mi az egészségi
állapota, mi a családi háttér, amiből
érkezik, mi történt vele,
>> és mi történt vele, hogy került oda?
>> Az ő szüleinek a kapcsolata tönkrement.
Az édesanyja úgy döntött, hogy a szülőja
úgy döntött, hogy hazaköltözik a
szüleihez.
Akkor ő várandós volt.
Négy plusz egy gyermeket nem tudott
hazavinni a szüleihez.
Választott
Annának a nővérét elvitte magával, és
Annát és a két bátját ott a
szülőapjánál.
aki nem tudott róluk gondoskodni.
Véletlenül annának a nagynényei,
az édesapjának a testvérei az igazság
ügybe dolgoznak, és nagyon tudták, hogy
fel kell hívni a gyermekvédelmet.
Eljöttek, elvitték őket. Anna akkor egy
éves és három hónapos volt.
Ez történt röviden.
>> És Anna látta, találkozott még a
szüleivel utána valaha.
Ez az, amit nem tudok kideríteni.
Vannak neki emlékei, de ezeket így
kezeljük, mint töredékeket. Nem tudunk
egyértelműen rájönni, hogy nagyon
gyakran biztos nem, mert négy és fél
éves volt, mikor örökbe fogadtam, nem
emlékezett. Voltak bizonyos emlékei,
talán jött valaki, talán,
de nem volt egyértelmű.
>> És utána mi történt? Tehát hazamentél,
emésgetted ezt gondolom egy pár napig
ezt a találkozást, utána mi történt? Mi
mi volt a következő lépés?
>> Az első találkozás után az első
találkozás után a szocmás mondta, hogy
ne rögtön írjam meg a lapot, pedig
mondtam, kapcsolódtunk, szerintem nem
kérdés. Nem, nem várd ki a három napot,
gondolkozzál. Természetesen elemeztem.
Én minden találkozásra úgy mentem a
következőre, hogy semmi okom nincs
visszautasítani gyermeket.
Tehát racionálisan
semmi okom nincs. Tehát nem történt
semmi olyan, ami felkeltette volna a
tehát megszólalt volna a vészcsengő,
hogy valami talán mégse úgy megy, ahogy
kell. És akkor mi? Mertogy igazából a
találtatás alatt bármikor le lehet
állítani a folyamatot. Tehát az, hogy
tovább mentem a második vagy a harmadik
vagy a negyedik találkozóra, nem azt
jelenti, hogy hazaviszem a gyereket. Nem
tudom megmondani, de ezt mindenki
eldöntheti magának, mert lehet hétközben
menni, lehet hétvégén elhozni. Annak
idején, amikor Annát örökbe fogadtam,
minden este vissza kellett vinni. Most
van egy olyan lehetőség, hogy elhozhatom
egész hétvégére, csak a leghosszabb
időszak, amire elhozhatom, ez egy hét.
Viszont iratokat kell, tehát szólni kell
előre a szocmásnak, és akkor elhozhatom
egy hétre a gyereket. Azt hiszem, nekem
adatott meg az a privilégium, hogy utol
pont az utolsó alkalommal én vittelek el
téged. Nem tudom, hogy így emlékszel-e
vissza, hogy az utolsó alkalom volt-e,
vagy
>> nem tudom, hogy te is azok között
voltál, akiket gyakran kértelek, hogy
hozzuk vigyük Annát, aki véglegesen
elhozta, tehát amikor össze volt
cucolva, meg amikor törvényszéki
határozat megérkezett, akkor egy másik
kollégám volt azon a reggelen. De te is
többször voltál?
>> Igen, egyikre emlékszem. Nagyon izgalmas
beszélgetés volt az autóban. És akkor
ugorjunk arra a pillanatra, amikor
meghoztad a döntést, és úgy döntötted,
hogy örökbe fogadod Annát. Milyen volt
az első pár nap?
>> Amikor
mielőtt teljes tehát
ugye a találtatás alatt születik
nagyjából meg a döntés, hogy
örökbefogadom. Ez azt jelenti, hogy
akkor születik egy bírói határozat, hogy
a gyerek hozzám költözhet a következő
három hónapra próbaidőre. Ühüm.
>> Ez az a dízidőszak, amikor még nem
cseréljük ki a nevét hivatalosan, ha
nevet szeretnénk cserélni neki, de a
családnevet se. Tehát ez még próbaidő,
ez a három hónap, amikor még mindig
vizsgálódom, hogy szeretném-e,
hogy
együtt maradjunk, nincsen-e akadálya
ennek.
Anna hozzánk került, és onnan kezdődött
el az összeszokás. Tehát az, amikor ő
megpróbált a családhoz igazodni, mi
megpróbáltunk hozzáigazodni.
U ugye nem voltunk hozzászokva egy
gyereknek az igényeihez. Nekünk addig
nem volt gyerekünk odahaza. Azért
használok többes számot, mert hogy abba
az időszakban édesanyám már velem
lakott, tehát a szívinfarkusa után
vagyunk.
Nagyon hozzá kellett szokni ahhoz, hogy
valaki dübörög a házba.
Az egyik problémám nekem az volt,
akármennyire nevetségesen hangzik, de
gondoljunk arra, hogy hol vannak vajon a
kis sarkak a lelkünkben, amiket úgy
megtartunk magunknak, és ott
kényeztetjük magunkat. Én reggel
tökéletes csendbe szoktam meginni a
kávémat.
Anna hajnalba ébredt,
és akkor amikor meghallotta, hogy kifőtt
a kávé, rögtön kijött. Na, ennek lőttek.
[nevetés] Tehát már felborította a
házirendet, már hozott valami mást. Meg
kellett szokni, hogy hogyan reagál,
amikor szeret valamit. Meg kellett
szokni, hogy hogyan reagál, amikor nem
szeret valamit, akkor látni kellett azt,
amikor szenved, amikor hozzá kellett
szokni
a mi családunknak a szabályaihoz. De ne
menjünk el a szabályaig,
hanem menjünk el odáig, hogy ő ugye
románul beszélt, mi meg magyarul
beszéltünk. És akkor nyilván amikor
egymáshoz szóltunk, ösztönösen, magyarul
szóltunk egymáshoz, és ő ebből mindig
kimaradt, és akkor ő közbeszólt, és
akkor fordítsd át romára az egészet.
Tehát ez már hozott újat a dinamikába,
ami időnként terhesnek és tűnt meg.
Az volt a terv, hogy tartjuk a
kapcsolatot a nevelőszülővel,
hogy könnyebben szokjon át a gyerek, de
hogy ugye hiányzott neki az a család,
ahol ott volt három évig teljesen
normális, és akkor mindig úgy nagyon
felbolydult
utána, és hát én érett és értelmes nőnek
tartom magam, meg pszichológus is
vagyok, de hogy mikor bekerülsz egy
személyes helyzetbe,
Akkor valahogy tehát nagyon érdekes volt
ez a kettős érzés, hogy egyrészt szinte
féltékeny voltam és rosszul esett, hogy
hiányzik neki a nevelő anyja és másrészt
meg ott álltam a tükör előtt és azt
mondta, de mit akarsz? Hát azt három éve
ismeri téged meg egy pontosan. Tehát,
hogy ez az egészséges, de hogy mégis
valahogy féltékeny voltam, meg nehéz
volt meg,
és
hát az ő érzelmeit meg az én érzelmeimet
kezelni sajnos ezen a területen nem
mindig vannak toppon, és
néha sérülékenységi pontoknak és
hibáknak könyvelik el ezeket, ha nem
tudod. Ö pedig teljesen normális
sérülékenységi felület, hogy hirtelen
összezavarodik az egész világod. Arra
emlékszem egy adott pontra, hogy eljött
a szocmás és magyarázta. Mondtam, hogy
hát most összeszokunk meg, hogy kezdődik
a kötődés. És akkor felmondta nekem a
kötődéselméletet. És csak annyit tudtam,
hogy nem mondja jól, amit mond, de hogy
nem, én magam előtt nem jöttem rá, hogy
mi a kötődésem, és így néztem, hogy
teljesen meghülyültem. Tehát nem tudom a
kötődés mi hogy létezik, vagy nem tudom.
Tehát ennyire összezavarja
a belsőket. Én
>> azt tapasztaltam, hogy a családunkban
minden gyermek születésénél a családunk
meg kellett halljon és újjá kellett
szülessen. Az elsőnél szörnyű volt,
tehát mint egy üstökös robbant be az
életünkben az első kislányom. Ö, a
második már könnyebb, de egy kisebb
üstökös. A harmadiknál még könnyebb
volt, de de minden egyes alkalommal ez a
mintázat jelen volt. Ez nem tudom, ez
ezt ezt alkalmazhatjuk. Te is így élted
meg, hogy
>> teljesen, mertogy igazából ugyanaz a
folyamat, kicsit másképp, de ha azt
vesszük, hogy igazából minden gyermeknek
a születése az az felnőttnek és a
gyermeknek az egyéniségétől is függ,
hogy hogy zajlik le, akkor valahogy
elköryvelhetjük így is. Persze az
örökbefogadó gyerek egy kicsit jobban ki
tudja fejezni, meg el tudja mondani,
hogy nem szeretem itt, vagy pedig nem
azról van szó, hogy nem szeret itt,
hanem arról van szó, hogy
új neki meg és ezek fájnak nekünk. Ezt
egy csecsemő nem mondja, de ugyanúgy
berobban az életbe. Én hozzá kell
szokjak a gyereket, a gyerek hozzám kell
szokjon. Tehát el kell kezdjünk volt,
mennyi idő után volt az első olyan
reggeled, amikor az volt az érzésed,
hogy kezd beállni egy stabilitás?
>> Ez egy olyan kérdés, amire nem tudok
válaszolni, de azt mondom meg, hogy
mikor állt be a stabilitás teljesen.
Mármint úgy, hogy azt mondtam, hogy most
már ez az én gyermekem, és ő tehát két
év,
>> két év kellett,
>> két év kellett. Mi? Ahogy haladtunk az
időben, egyre jobb lett. Tehát minden
egyre jobb lett. A legeleje volt a
legnehezebb, aztán hogy haladtunk, egyre
jobb lett. De hogy mindig mindig voltak
olyan pontok, amikor mondtam, most már
most már itt van, most már itthon van,
most már az enyém. Aztán utána jobb
lett. Na most már az enyém. Aztán megint
jobb lett. Na most már az enyém. És
akkor úgy körülbelül két-két és fél év
után nem volt egy olyan, hogy na most
már itthon van, hanem annál a most már
itthon van, annál maradtunk. Tehát egy
olyan két két és fél év.
>> És akkor ez alatt a a kéti két és fél év
alatt voltak olyan gondolataid, hogy
esetleg megbántad, hogy hogy
meglépted ezt a lépést?
>> Azt, hogy megbántam, azt nem, hanem
ilyen jó anya mintára, ami Erdélyben egy
különösen jó anyaminta, tehát a
lelkiismeret fordulás meg, hogy mennyire
tudom jól csinálni a dolgokat. Tehát
olyan volt, hogy tönkre fogom tenni ezt
a gyermeket, mert még csak azt se tudom
megérteni, hogy ő ragaszkodik ahhoz a
nevelőanyához. Pedig tudom racionális.
>> Mennyi év volt amúgy ez az ragaszkodás?
Mennyi ideig tartott?
>> Sajnos én elvágtam a a kapcsolatot
velük, mert nem tudtam kezelni a
igazából a saját érzelmi folyamataimat.
Tehát ezt teljesen megengedik.
Ö ami lehet, hogy mivel nem mediálnak,
akkor ez jobb is, ha megengedik, mert
mindenki csak azt tudja kibírni, amit
kibír.
>> Ühüm.
>> És akkor egy adott ponton szóltam a
hölgynek, hogy szeretném, hogyha nem
beszélnénk most már hetente, mert nagyon
felkavarja a gyereket. Mondtam, hogy
vissza fogunk térni, csak mire
visszatértünk volna, Anna annyira átállt
a családhoz. Ezt mondjuk egy ezt ki is
jelenthetően érdekes. Ő ezeket
azt mondta, hogy ez az én családom és
most már innen kezdve magyarul beszélek.
Tehát februárban elhoztam, július elején
még nem beszélt magyarul, július végén
nem beszélt románul.
>> Ühüm.
>> Kész. Tehát ez ennyire átállt.
>> És mikor volt az, amikor úgy
természetesen h hogy szólít most amúgy
Anna téged?
>> Anya. És mikor volt az, amikor először
így természetesen anyának szólít ezt ez
egyáltalán ezt a folyamatot ezt hogyan
képzeljem el? Elmondtad neki, hogy most
az anyának szólítsa, és
>> hát igen, mert ezt elmondjuk, hogy mit
lehet meg mit nem lehet, és akkor én
anya vagyok, ő nagyi
meg ő Hajni meg Attila. Tehát ki
kicsoda? Ez a te ágyad, itt fogsz
aludni, ez a te szobád, itt van minden
dolgod. Tehát úgy bemutatjuk a
környezetet a gyereknek, hogy
beszoktassuk a saját környezetébe. Mi az
a tér, amit ő birtokba vehet, ahol azt
csinálhat, amit akar, és akkor nyilván,
hogy hogyan szorítson.
>> És akkor ez volt az anya, ami nyilván
nem volt egyszerű megoldás, de arra
gondoltam, hogy kétszer rászoktatni
valamire sokkal rosszabb, inkább szokjon
meg valamit akkor is, ha nem ejti
tisztán
>> első perctől kezdve. Tehát inkább
szókjon rá arra, hogy anya, akkor is, ha
anya, vagy bármi mást mondott eleinte,
de hogy ne két tanulási folyamaton
menjünk keresztül. A nehézség akkor
adódott, amikor ez
az én folyamatomban ez nem volt
átbeszélve, hogy mikor lehet a nevét
megváltoztatni. Annának a nevét nem
lehetett magyarra lefordítani. Úgyhogy
ez az áloma, hogy Anna lesz, ez teljesen
bejött akkor így. De ezzel is rengeteget
vívódtam, hogy
>> most megváltozik a neve, eléggé
megszenvedte, tiltakozott és egy kicsit
ellene
nehezen indult, aztán utána teljesen
beleszokott ebbe az egész történetbe, és
akkor megint az is volt, hogy ő Anna, én
meg Anya. Tehát na összecsengtek a
szavak. Visszaemlékszel, hogy volt-e
olyan félelmed
így utólag visszagondolva, amit most egy
kicsit így naívnak gondolsz, hogy
fölöslegesen féltél dolgoktól és és
beigazolódottod, hogy most már ennyi év
után, hogy ez fölösleges volt? Szerintem
minden olyan sztereotípia, ami
megnyilvánult bárkinél, akár
örökbefogadót gyermeke van, akár
saját gyermeke, merthogy én megértem,
hogy egyesek tesznek különbséget, de
hogy bennem ez soha nem volt meg, és
ezért saját szemszögből nem tudok
erreflektálni,
de hogy nem leszek elég jó anya,
>> hogy nem tudok magammal kapcsolatban
voltak ezek mindig ezek a
bizonytalanságok, hogy nagyon szeretnék
gyereket, de lehet, hogy nem tudok anya
lenni.
Nézd meg, szenved a gyermek. Tehát
nyilvánvaló, hogy szenved, ki lett
szakítva egy másik környezetből, tehát
azt azt meg kell dolgozni, de szenved a
gyermek. Ez azt jelenti, hogy nem vagyok
elég jó anya.
>> Ugye nem tudom, tönkre fogom tenni a
gyereket. Tehát a katasztrófa az ott
volt.
>> És ezt feloldott benned, akkor egy idő
után már ki tudtad mondani, hogy én elég
jó vagyok.
Hát ez ezek önismereti folyamatok, meg
így saját magát kezeli az ember, ha már
pszichológus, akkor elmond volt
szerinted?
>> Hát ez mindig, hát ez körkörösen, ez
ciklikus. Tehát mindig, amikor valami
történik, vagy valamit eltúulzol, vagy
valamit tévedsz, vagy nem is tévedsz,
csak egy kicsit robbanásszerűbb lesz a
helyzet, nem engedem meg, hogy ebéd
előtt csokit egyen, mikor amúgy is
rosszul eszik, tehát egyszer egye meg, s
akkor lesz belőle egy nagy robban. Hát
nyilván nem tudtam kezelni a gyermeket,
nem? Tehát ezek ciklikusan előjönnek,
aztán utána oda kell állni, hogy elég jó
anya kell legyek. Ezt valaki egyszer
megtanította nekem, hogy a klienseimmel
így dolgozzak. Ugye klinikai
pszichológus vagyok, elég jó anyának
kell lenni. És akkor elkezdtem magamra
használni ezt. Még él a gyermek, evett.
>> Azt jelenti, hogy elég jó anya vagyok.
>> Igen. Igen. Igen. Tehát ez az elég jó
érzés. Ez ez pontosan úgy, ahogy leírod,
ez kell, mert tökéletesek nem leszünk.
Azt hiszem, ez a generáció az, amelyik
>> túlságosan sokat tud és tépi magát
folyamatosan. Legtöbbet tud és a leg
leginkább bizonytalan. Hát a legtöbbet
tud, de felületes
ö fogalmak szintjén, tehát igazából
azzal is marcangoljuk magunkat, hogy mi
a szülői felelősségünk, merthogy másképp
képzeljük el, meg másképp képzeljük, mi
a mi a gyermeknek az érzelmi
szükséglete. Annyit hallom ezt az
érzelmi szükségletet, azért nem
>> tiltom meg a gyereknek, hogy rajzfilmet
nézzen, mert sírni fog és sérül az
érzelmi szükséglete. Bocsánat, a
kényelmes sérül, nem az érzelmi
szükséglete.
Ez két külön dolog. Tehát szerintem ez
nagyon gátol minket, hogy tudunk
információkat.
Nagyon használunk egy olyan
szakszöveget, amit nem értünk meg, és
ami árnyalt, és egy puzzleszerű, sok
darabból tevődik összes. Akkor ezt a sok
darabot nem feltétlenül tudjuk kezelni
és helyére rakni, és ilyenkor nem ártana
segítséget kérni.
Én visszatérnék arra a momentumra,
amikor először találkoztál Annával, úgy
és azért is térnék vissza, mert
gyakorlatilag most másodszor is ugyan
ebbe a helyzetbe, vagy, hogy hogy fogod
látogatni a gyermekeket,
hogy ilyenkor el tudom képzelni, hogy a
gyermekek megpróbálnak megfelelni ennek
a mert mert érzik valahonnan, vagy vagy
nem tudom, tudják-e hogy mi is történik
itt pontosan, de hogy ez ez egy érdekes
dinamikát hoz be. Ezt tapasztaltad amúgy
te is, vagy igazából, mivel Anna volt az
első gyermek, akivel találkoztál, de
hogy hogy biztos, hogy benne
utánanéztél, vagy vagy mi a véleményed
erről, hogy hogy ezek a gyermekek hogyan
viszonyulnak a látogatókhoz?
>> Ez pontosan így van, ahogy elmondtad.
Annak ellenére, hogy elméletileg védjük
a gyerekeket, és nem mondják el neki,
hogy ez a néni bácsi, aki jön, lehet,
hogy anyukád vagy apukád lesz.
Anna szerint, mert most a második
folyamatba kerültünk olyan helyzetbe,
hogy látogassunk meg egy másik gyereket.
Anna azt mondta, hogy anya, ti felnőttek
azt hiszitek, hogy nem tudjuk, de mi
gyermekek tudjuk, tudjuk, hogy azért
jösztök.
Tehát valahonnan leszívják a levegőből,
valahonnan érzik ezt. És igen, az első
alkalom az az, amikor nagyon pörögnek,
és meg akarják mutatni, hogy milyen
ügyesek és aranyosak és satöbbi.
Azonban az első látogatások után ugye
következnek a következő látogatások. Ha
elég gyakran látogatom a gyereket, utána
megfordul egy picit a dinamika, mert a
gyermek utána a saját
pszichés terét ki akarja jelölni, és
akkor egy kicsit megpróbálja, hogy hol
vannak a határok, és azt is megpróbálja,
hogy a határok azok határok, vagy csak
vonalak a homokba.
Ez egy olyan helyzet, amikor a fél
boltot fel akarja vásárolni,
vagy vásároltatni veled, és akkor azt
mondod, hogy hát márpedig nem. És akkor
>> ez még az ismerkedési,
>> ez még az ismerkedési időszakban, amikor
nincs elhozva. Tehát mindenkinek az
eredeti család, a nevelőszülői
családjába valamit szeretne vinni, mert
ő most Kolozsváron járt, és akkor ő most
bevásárol a te pénztárcádra, és nem is
arról van szó, hogy vásárol vagy nem
vásárol a pénztárcára, csak annyi
mindent nem vásárolunk össze. Meg
valahol meg kell húzni a határt, és
akkor elkezdődik a histüm.
>> Pont úgy, mintogyha egy éven állam
laknam.
És akkor ilyenkor, hogy kezeled? Tehát,
hogy ott van a hiszti és
ez amúgy nem csak az ismerkedési fázisra
érvényes, hanem később is. Tehát a
fegyelmezésnél
kemény határhúzások vannak ott egy benne
van egy elutasítás is. Tehát az a amit
te kérsz, az nem megfelelő. Ez nem nem
helyes. És én bennem így az van, hogy
hogy egy gyermek, amelyik amúgy is
bizonytalan abban, hogy maradhat-e az
identitásában, tehát hogy a
gyermekeimnek nem kérdés, hogy én
maradok-e. Egész születésük óta minden
szinte minden este otthon aludtam.
annyira, mint a levegő körbeveszem őket,
hogy nem is kérdés, hogy maradok-e, de
egy örökbefogadott gyermeknél gyanítom,
hogy nem ez az életérzése van, hogy az a
amit most most körbevesz, az stabil,
mert elutasított a a biológiai anyja és
apja, a a nevelőszülőkistől
is elkerült, és most ott van egy valaki,
akit anyának kell szólítson, és aki most
azt mondja nekem, hogy ezt nem kaphatom
meg. Tehát hogyha ha erre gondolok,
akkor azt látom, hogy az identitásában
mélyen mélyen meg is kérdőjelezheti azt,
hogy hogy most ez a nem ez a ez a a
lényemre vonatkozik, vagy ténylegesen
arra a cselekedetemre. És gyanítom, hogy
a lényére gondol, hogy engem utasít el.
>> Ez teljesen így van, ahogy mondod.
Viszont különbséget kell tegyünk a az
egyéni események és a folyamatok között.
Tehát
úszom a vízbe és megfuladok, vagy nem
fulladok meg, és akkor azt látom, hogy
fennart az öv. Következő alkalommal is
attól félek, hogy megfuladok a vízbe, de
megint fenntart az öv. Tehát igazából
az, hogy utána repetitíven egy ilyen
helyzet után azt éli meg, hogy továbbra
is ott vagyok,
de hogy teljesen alá tudom írni, hogy
egy ilyen nem és egy ilyen meghúzott
határ és egy határozottan meghúzott
határ a személyének az elutasítása, nem
a kérésének. Többek között Anna
megkérdezte, hogy mikor megy a következő
anyjához.
>> Ühüm.
>> Tehát ez ennyire ez a szülői fogalom és
ez az anyai fogalom és a család. És
akkor mit mondtál?
>> Mondtam, hogy te most megérkeztél a te
családodban. Ez a te családod. Én a te
anyád vagyok. Mármint, hogy nem ő az én
lányom, hanem én vagyok az ő anyja.
>> Hm.
>> Ez ez a te otthonod
itt. Te itthon vagy.
Aki bizonytalan, annak bizonyosság kell.
És akkor ilyenkor megnyugtatja, és akkor
újra feljön később, és újra, és akkor
párszor meg kell ismerni.
>> Igen, ez párszor. A párszor az évek.
>> Az évek.
És ez feljöhet kétszer egy héten, vagy
feljöhet
minden nap az egyik héten, és a
következő évig nem jön fel, de a
következő évben megint, amikor
az én támadva van, vagy egy másik
fejlődési kihívás előtt áll, és akkor
megint kipróbálja, hogy ott vagyok-e.
>> Most Anna 13 éves, hogy
>> 11 12 lesz augusztusban.
>> Bocsánat 12 lesz augusztusban.
>> Lesz augusztusban.
Így 11 és mindjárt 12 évesen most már
hogy érzed be legyökerezett a a szívébe,
az identitásába az, hogy te vagy az
anyja?
>> Történetet mesélek. Jó,
>> szuper.
>> Az iskolába a lányok eldöntötték, hogy
kihúznak egy-egy szetlit, és
megajándékozzák egymást.
elvitte az ő ajándékát a a
barátnőjének,
és úgy érezte annak fényében, ami
történt az iskolában, hogy ez túl kevés.
Van neki egy okosórája, kiment szünetbe,
felhívott és azt mondta: "Aya,
szeretném, ha még vennél ezt, ezt, ezt,
ezt, ezt Rebekának, és mikor
kicsengetnek és hazamegyünk, légy szíves
légy az iskola előtt, mert még azt oda
szeretném adni" és lezárta.
És olyan biztos volt benne, hogy én az
iskola előtt leszek azokkal a dolgokkal,
hogy nem kellett se visszaigazoljam,
nem is hívott fel többet.
Szerintem igen.
Olyan biztos volt, hogy ott leszek a
kapu előtt, hogy
>> remélem ott voltál.
>> Természetesen ott voltam. Ezt mondom,
hogy csak kijött, megnézte, hogy hol
vagyok. Teljesen biztos volt benne,
>> hogy ott leszek.
És most így
vannak-e néha
kérdései,
hogy mi volt a a az eredeti szüleivel?
>> Ezek a kérdések időről időre feljönnek.
Csak, hogy most már elismételtük egy
párszor így hét év után.
És
>> ilyenkor mit mondasz neki?
>> Az eredeti szüleivel kapcsol azt a
történetet, amit tudok.
Úgy, hogy az eredeti szülőket nem
hibáztatjuk.
Nem éltük az életüket, nem tudjuk, mi
történt velük.
Objektíven a történetekre
fókuszálunk,
és a legkedvezőbb érzelmi forgatókönyvet
adjuk ennek az egésznek.
Nem bírta tovább, nem egyeztek, el
kellett menni, nem vihetett magával,
biztonságba kerültetek. Mikor rájött,
hogy nem fog titeket felnevelni, akkor
elengedett, hogy legyen családotok,
>> hogy kapjatok jó nevelést, mert
tarthatott volna az intézménybe,
és sose lett volna családod.
Hálásak vagyunk neki. Te amúgy is az én
lányom voltál kezdettől fogva. Ő
megszült nekem. Ha nagy leszel és látni
szeretnéd, meglátogatjuk, megköszönjük
neki, hogy életet adott neked.
Ez a történet.
Nem volt ő elhagyva. Ez volt a legjobb
forgatókönyv, hogy elkerüljön hozzám.
Istennek különböző megoldásai vannak.
Nem csak úgy lehet egy anyas, egy gyerek
együtt, hogy beleszületik a családba,
nem születhetett meg nálam, megszületett
máshol, és utána hozzám került.
Egyébként van egy történet, hogy előttem
volt még egy szülő, és pont ez volt a
kérdése, hogy anya, az a néni, miért nem
akart engem?
>> És azt mondtam, hogy nagyon akart téged,
Anna, édes, csak Isten vigyázzott, hogy
ne tévedj el. Bezárta a szívét, hogy te
kerülj hozzám.
Te nagyon magány kislány vagy. És
tényleg az,
>> de egyébként tervben van. Tehát
elmondtam, hogy ha felnőtt korában
szeretné majd meglátogatni a a
vérszerinti rokonait,
szülőanyját, szülőapját, azt hiszem,
hogy ő már nem él, de meglátjuk
testvéreit.
A törvényszékhez kell fordulni. kérvényt
leadunk, megkeresik őket és
>> azóta nem találkozott a testvérei
>> nem találkozhat, mert nálunk Romániában
csak zárt adopciók vannak. A zárt
adopció az azt jelenti, hogy a
vérszerinti rokonokkal nem tartja többet
a kapcsolatot. Amerikában van nyitott
adopció és ott a szülőanya kap
értesítést a gyerekről, képeket kap
róla,
>> de nálunk csak zárt adopciók vannak.
>> És szerinted jobb-e ez a rendszer a zárt
adopcióval?
Úgy gondolom, hogyha nincsen egy segítő
rendszer, amelyik támogassa úgy az
örökbefogadó, mint a szülő szülőt,
jobb, hogyha az át,
>> aki mediális közben megsegít.
>> Hát persze, tehát szakszerűen meg
határokat tartva.
>> Ühüm. Igen. Hogy ne tekerjen megvéd a a
polcsá. Igen.
>> Így igaz. Így igaz, hogy ne az legyen,
hogy akkor buújtogassa a gyereket, vagy
valami, mert hogy én vagyok igazából a
te anyád. Nem nevellek, de én vagyok
igazából a te anyád, tehát ez nem
hiányzik.
>> És az, hogy még egyet örökbe fogadnál,
még egy gyermeket, ezt Anna fogadja?
>> Hát azért hét év után fogadjuk örökbe,
mert ő most ért ide.
>> Én amikor elindítottam az örökbefogadási
folyamatot, akkor én eleve két gyereket
kértem.
Aztán úgy alakult, hogy csak egy
gyerekre adták meg a
az engedélyt.
Nem kommentálom, miért nem is érdemes
ebbe belemenni. Utána úgy tűnt, hogy
annyira féltékeny és annyira nem bírná
el valakinek a jelenlétét a közelemben,
hogy se neki, se a másik gyereknek nem
tenne jót. Egy kicsit fájdalommal
vettem, de apropó dinamika, tehát ugye
már van valaki a családban, és őt
figyelembe kell venni a következő
adopciónál, ugye?
>> Meg kell segítsen is neked, nem csak
eltűrjen, hanem
>> nyilván, nyilván. És már ott voltam,
hogy hát lehet, hogy itt nem lesz két
gyerek, csak egy gyerek, mert nem lesz
jó neki se, talán nem lesz jó a másik
gyereknek se, ha ez a gyerek haragszik
rá.
És aztán egyszer csak megfordult az
egész történet
gyakorlatilag
a körül
amikor a testvérem és örök befogadtak,
és akkor úgy valahogy átíródott ez a
forgatókönyv, de idő kellett hozzá, idő
kellett hozzá. Nem állítom, hogy most
nem féltéken, csak sokkal jobban bírja.
>> Sokkal jobban bírja.
>> Az, hogy a testvéreid örökbe fogadtak,
annak gondolom, hogy komoly komoly oka
volt, hogy látták Annát.
>> Igen,
>> igen,
>> igen.
>> Még van hasonló történet a
környezetedben, akit inspirált ez a
történet, és emiatt indult el ezen az
úton?
>> Nem tudom ennyire konkrétan lehet, de
nem tudom ráfogni. Most maj remélem a
podcast hatására már
>> akik amúgy is a határon vannak, hogy
hogy elinduljonak, csak éppen nem
tudják, mi az első lépés.
Kíváncsi vagyok.
>> Hát ez most nem a reklám helye meg nem
is tudom, hogyha van hely egy podcastb,
de én szívesen szóba állok bárkivel, aki
úgy gondolja, hogy segíteni tudok.
>> Gyanítom, lesznek jelentkezők. Gyanítom,
hogy lesznek jelentkezők. Ha lesznek,
akkor lesz válasz is.
>> Egy kicsit térjünk át a kihívásokra,
amiket hoz a az örök befogadás. Most az
egyik kihívás az a amúgy a biológiai
gyermek esetén is, meg biológiai
szülőség esetén is ott van az a
csalogató
tendencia,
hogy mártír szülőnek a szerepébe
kerüljünk, hogy én mennyi mindent
kellett feláldozzak érted, én mennyi
minden áldozatot hoztam azért, hogy te
lehessél. ez a biológiai gyermekeddel
is. És olyan csalogató néha ebbe a
szerepbe belekerülni, hogy így neveljük,
hogy így próbáljuk
>> lelkiismeret fordulásra kényszer
kényszeríteni a gyermeket, hogy én
milyen jó anya vagyok és te milyen
hálátlan valaki vagy. Na most el tudom
képzelni, hogy ebben a dinamikában ez
duplán érvényes, hogy ráadásul én
mentettelek meg téged a a én vagyok a
megváltó, aki elmentem és elhoztalak
arról a rossz- rossz helyről és most itt
vagy a téged is csalogatott ez az érzés.
Nem, merthogy én
most nem tudom, hogy mennyire menjünk
ebbe bele, hogy én egy kicsit egy
>> menjünk bele, nem tudom mibe, de
menjünk.
Én egy kicsit egy bántalmazásosabb
családi környezetből jövök, és én
mindenér hibás voltam, azért is, hogy
felkelt a nap, azért is, hogy lefeküdt.
>> Tehát én mindenért magamat hibáztatom
legelőször bármilyen helyzetbe, tehát
munkahelyi helyzetbe, és
azt látom meghamarább, hogy én mit
kellett volna másképp csináljak. Tehát
nekem nem az jut eszembe először, hogy
igazam van. Az már a második, amikor
feldühődök, az a második lépés. Tehát
engem nem, de el tudom képzelni, hogy ez
lehet, én úgy gondolom, hogy mindenkit a
saját sérülékenységi pontjai mentén
jönnek ezek az akadályok, vagy ezek a
botlasztók, nevezzük így.
>> Nyilván, hogyha van egy nagy fájdalom a
szívemben, hogy én szeretnék egy
természetes gyereket, és
valamilyen oknál fogva nehezen tudom
elfogadni. Most annyira pozitívan
fogalmazok, amennyire lehet. Nem
szeretnék senkit megbántani. Mindenki a
saját megéléseivel van, mindenki a saját
lelkét érzi. Tehát érzek valamit, ami
miatt az örökbefogadott gyermeket nem
érzem
ugyanolyan
értékű saját gyermeknek, akkor ilyenkor
könnyebben kibújik a felnőttből is.
Viszont a történet az az nálam, tehát a
változás az mindig nálam van, nem a
másiknál bármilyen kapcsolatban. És
akkor ezeket az érzelmeimet, akár a
bűntudatot, vagy akár a bűntudatkeltést,
ha észreveszem magamba, akkor kezdjek
valamit vele.
Merthogy a gyermek egy adott ponton
érezheti annyira méltatlannak magát,
hogy végül méltatlan lesz.
>> Ühüm. Tehát egy önbeteljesítő jóslat
lesz, hogy te hálátlan gyermek, akit
kimostalak a koszból és családot és
mindent adtam neki, és akkor azt mondja,
hát tényleg. És akkor elkezd új
viselkedni, mintha
>> tehát szerintem ez
>> mi a mélyebb igazság itt? Te hogyan
fogalmaznád meg, hogyha valaki csúszik
ebbe az irányba, hogy hogy ezzel a
mártír szülő szereppel takarozózzon? Te
mit tanácsolnál ennek a a hogyan
ébredjen fel ebből a tévútból, ami
önbeteljesítő jóslattá válhat?
>> Hát van egy általánosabb tanácsom és van
egy gyakorlati tanácsom. Tehát hogyha
nem szeretné, hogy beteljesedjen a
gyakorlati tanács mentén,
jó lenne változtatni ezen az attitűdön.
Teljesen egyértelmű, hogy nem könnyű
szülőnek lenni, és hogy áldozatot
vállalok, de hogy igazából
ezt jelenti szülőnek lenni.
hogy attól kezdve, hogy egy gyermek van
a házamban,
felelős vagyok az ő fejlődéséért.
És az a gyermek attól gyermek, hogy még
nincs kifejlődve, tehát ugyanazokat a
felelősségeket és szerepeket nem
vállalhatja, és nem ugyanúgy fordíthatja
vissza. Tehát igazából, ha mindent
megteszek a gyermekemért, akkor vagyok
jó szülő.
>> De akkor ezt miért kell neki elmondani?
Most még az jutott eszembe ezzel
kapcsolatban, hogy egyik karácsonykor rá
kellett jöjjünk arra, hogy egy szörnyű
tapasztalat volt. Vettünk egy jó pár
ajándékot, és akkor a gyerekek
berohantak és széttépték az ajándékot,
és meg voltak őrülve, dobálták az
ajándékot, mert örömükbe, és olyan
rosszul esett a feleségemmel ez az egész
eset, hogy
na gondolkoztunk rajta. Valami nem jó,
valami megfordult itt karácsonykor.
>> És az egyik dolog, amit megfogalmaztunk,
az az, hogy ez a mi felelősségünk, hogy
nem tanítottuk meg őket hálásnak lenni.
Ők nem tudják, hogy mi a hála, mert ők
még kicsi gyerekek, és mi kell
megtanítsuk, mert nekünk eszünkben nem
jutott, hogy meg kell tanítani, de úgy
leesett így a a gondolat, hogy
>> jó, hát akkor akkor meg kell tanítsuk.
És akkor fogtuk az ajándékot, és akkor
azt mondtuk, hogy most újra játszuk az
egészet. Itt van az ölöttben az ajándék.
Az első lépés az, hogy megköszönöd,
utána megkérdezed, hogy kibonthatod,
utána óvatosan kibontod, de nem úgy,
hogy szétted az ajándékot, mint egy egy
vadállat, hanem csak szépen. És úgy
megtanítani a gyereket hálásnak a
szülőnek a feladata. Viszont és és ez ez
nem ugyanaz, mint kizsarolni érzelmileg
a gyerekből a hálát.
>> Tehát az egyik első feladatunk, amikor
onnan hozzánk került, az az, hogy
mindent megköszöntünk.
De tényleg így beszélünk, tehát hozz
légys szíves egy pohárvízet, köszönöm
szépen. És akkor őt nem monda, és akkor
mondtam, hogy én megköszöntem neked,
megköszönött is nekem.
És pár hónap múlva bementünk valakinek
az irodájába, és mondom, adj légy szíves
egy poár vizet neki, mert szomjas. És
amikor átnyújtotta poárvizet, annak
köszönöm. Na ez igen, azt mondja az
illető. De hogy pont erről van szó, amit
te mondtál. Tehát ha azt szeretném, hogy
udvarias legyen, tehát azt hiszem, és
ebben van valami, hogy a példaereje
nevel, de hogy nem mindent fog
észrevenni a gyermek, mert nem minden
kerül a figyelmének a középpontjába.
És akkor azt, hogy hogyan legyen
udvarias, vagy hogyan legyen empátiás,
ha nem jön neki zsigerből, azt meg kell
tanítani. Sőt, mondom tovább a dolgokat.
Lassan, minél jobban előrehalad az
iskolába, elvárjuk, hogy tanuljon.
Hogyan is kell tanulni? Vajon tudja-e a
gyerek, hogy kell megtanulja a leckéjét?
Vagy csak megmondom neki, hogy na ezt
aztán tudjad, mire visszajöttem.
De leülők mellé, ha nehézséget okoz,
mert van gyerek, akinek tehát
különbözőek a gyerekek, és nem
mindegyiknek ugyanaz a botlasztója, de
ha valamit nem úgy csinál, ahogy én
szeretném, akkor lehet, hogy valamit nem
tud. Meg kell tanítani, hálásnak lenni.
Vagy nekem bennem ez a tanulás most
azért ilyen nagyon élénk, mert rájöttem,
hogy Anna nem tudja a földrajzot és a
történelmet megtanulni, és akkor szépen
vettük a könyvet és a főzetet, és akkor
tanítjuk tanulni. Elolvasol mindent,
megnézed, hogy melyikek azok a fontos
információpontok, goc pontok. Megnézzük,
mi az, amit meg kell tanulni. Tehát azt,
hogy bukurató, azt nem tudom logikailag
lekövetkeztetni. Azt meg kell tanulni,
hogy bukura. Ez van. hogy az se, hogy
miért így alakult egy földrész, vagy
hogy a az országhatárok miért így
alakulnak.
>> Amúgy racionálisabb, reálisabb
beállítottságú vannak.
>> Persze. Igen. És ezt akkor mikor
rendszert fogok kezébe adni, ezt könnyen
meg fogja tenni egyedül, de most per
pillanat együtt tanuljuk minden nap.
Tanulunk földrajzot, tanulunk
történelmet, tanulunk
természetismeretet.
>> Hogyan tudott Anna beilleszkedni az
iskolába vagy a közösségekbe?
Elmondtátok, vagy tudják, hogy egy
örökbefogadott kislány? Ő
>> sose volt titok.
Tankönyv szerint kezeltük. Lehet, hogy
egyesek úgy érzik, hogy szerencsénk is
volt. Olyan környezetet találtunk, ahol
megértés van, és és ezt szeretettel
fogadják.
Ö természetesen a gyerekek, ha bántani
akarnak, akkor mindig valami olyasmit
találnak ki, ami egy fájópont, és hamar
rájönnek néha, hogy ez is lehet egy
fájópont, úgy ahogy egy nagy orr, vagy
egy nagy fül lehet egy fájópont, vagy
tehát az ami a sérülékenységi pontja a
gyereknek, de a környezetbe azt tudják,
szépen van kezelve az iskolába, annem
>> volt volt rá példa, hogy csúfolták,
>> hogy csúfolták, nem, de hogy habár arra
is most, hogy eszembe jut, tehát volt
olyan olyan helyzet, hogy ugye mindenki
tudja, hogy örökben van fogadva, hogy
egy adott ponton megharagodott rá egy
kisfió, és akkor azt mondta, hogy mert
te cigány vagy,
és ann
>> hát ez nem ugyanaz.
>> Hát
közvetve ugyanaz, tehát hogyha örökbe
vagy fogadva, akkor mi más lehetsz?
Tehát ez ilyen szempontból
>> ühüm
>> jött. Tehát látszólag nem ugyanaz, de
igazából ugyanaz. Üüm.
>> És hogy kezeltétek ezt a helyzetet? Hát
mondjuk ezt a konkrét helyzetet úgy
kezeltem, hogy felhívtam a kisfiúnak az
édesanyját, és elmondtam, hogy mi
történt. Természetesen rögtön
hát mi egy nagyon kulturált környezetbe
lakunk.
Összeültünk egy délután és megbeszéltük
a történteket. A kisfiú bocsánatot kért.
Én megdicsértem a kisfiút, hogy ennyire
bátor bocsánatot kér, mert ez magától
érthetődő, ugye.
>> Igen. De amúgy kér bocsánatot, hogy hogy
Annától négy szem közülő találkoztak
előttünk. Igen, előttünk, de hogy utána
meg bementek játszani.
>> Tehát tényleg valós megbocsátás, meg
rendben voltak, meg utána rendben voltak
kint ott ők összezördültek. A kisfiú
tudta, hogy örökbe van fogadva. Ög csak
a most használom ezt a szót, de igazából
csak a cigányok követnek el rossz
dolgokat, ugye, meg többek között
elhagyják a gyermekeiket. Tehát Anna
cigány.
>> Ühüm.
>> Mondjuk egyébként jogilag magyar, mert
most meg az anyja magyar.
[nevetés]
És így van beírva. Nem tudom, biztos
tudjátok, hogy beírják a gyerekeket az
anyuk nemzetisége szerint, hogy
micsodák.
Amúgy ez mennyire igaz ez a
sztereotípia, hogy az örök befogadható
gyermekek nagy része gondolom akkor ezek
szerint cigány.
>> Hát nagy része, de nem mindenki.
>> Ühüm.
>> Nagy része.
>> Erről van-e valamilyen statisztikád,
hogy hány százaléka?
>> Egy ilyen statisztikát azért nem
készítenek, meg nem
tesznek nyilván nem hoznak
nyilvánosságra, mert mert immorális.
Tehát nem szabad ilyet, hogy pont mintha
azt számolnánk, hogy hány fehér meg hány
fekete végez el valamint
Amerikába. Tehát
>> amúgy ezekről vannak statisztikák.
>> Vannak statisztikák, de más
helyzetekben, más
nem a gyerekekkel kapcsolatban, hanem
állásfoglalás, bűnözés, ilyesmi, de nem
az elhagyott gyerek, tehát a gyerekekkel
nem
>> ez egy olyan dolog, ami megerősítene
sztereotípiákat.
>> Az biztos. Az biztos. Egy kicsit még
táncolok ezeken a sztereotípiákon, tehát
hogy
>> hagyom, hogy te védjed ezeket.
>> Leszek én megint az ördög ügyvédje.
Volt-e benned félelem amiatt, hogy ő
milyen múlttal rendelkezik, hogy
genetikailag áthoz valami olyasmit, ami
ami később fog kibukni, vagy ezután fog
kibukni? Ö
>> és egy egy félelmet keltő,
kontrollálatlan direkt hagyom, hogy te
egészítsd ki magadba ezeket a dolgokat.
Én megértek mindenkit, akinek hasonló
félelmei vannak, mert az, hogy nature
versus nurture, tehát hogy mi az, ami
genetika és mi az, ami nevelés,
>> ez ez tudományosan még mindig nem egy
lezongorázott téma, de biztos, hogy a
gyerek hozza a személyiségét, de bennem
mindig az volt, tehát ezekkel a
dolgokkal, amik félelmet keltettek
bennem, nem lesz a gyerek nekem elég
okos, mert nekem, hogy elég fontos az,
hogy ez az intelekt intellektuális
szféra. És akkor odaállok a tükör elé,
és azt mondom, hogy ha én szülök holnap
egy gyereket,
az Einstein lesz-e?
És akkor azt mondom, hogy hát nem.
És ha én szülök holnap egy gyereket,
garantálni tudom-e, hogy soha nem lop
meg senkit?
És a válasz az, hogy nem.
>> Igen.
>> És tudom-e garantálni, hogy 16 évesen
nem szökik-e meg Rómeóval?
És a válasz az az, hogy nem. És ehhez
nem kell bizonyos genetikai háttér.
Tehát előttem van egy gyönyörű, ha már a
sztereotípiákkal játszunk, van
sztereotípia ellenes, egy gyönyörű
szőke, kékzemű kislány. Egyetlen gyereke
a szüleinek, ahol az apa nagyon szigorú,
az anya nagyon megengedő, mindent utána
engedett, fantasztikusan szerepel.
egészen hatodik osztályig olimpiászokat
nyer meg mindenféle és nyolcadikba
kiszöik egy Róma fiúval.
Pont azért, mert a levállási krízis
olyan erős lett a családban, hogy olyat
tett, ami megrázó volt a szülei számára,
hogy értsek meg, hogy ő felnő, de hogy
onnan kezdve már nehéz is visszakaparni.
Üüm.
>> És akkor itt mi volt a genetika ezzel a
kislánnyal? Mondjuk azt mondtad, hogy
erre nincsen tudományos konszenzus, de
azt hiszem most már kimondhatjuk azt,
hogy faji alapon nincs ilyen konklúzió,
hogy ha valaki cigány, akkor ez a kép,
>> hát ez meg a másik. Tehát ebben biztosak
lehetünk, hogy
>> ez meg a másik, hogy és megint megint
szintén a romákkal kapcsolatban, tehát
nekünk tapasztalatunk volt az, hogy Tani
tud élni, mert ugye ki vannak sodrodva a
társadalom perifériáraára.
kolléganőm elmegy, hogy iratokat
nekik azonossági iratokat
beszerezni, segít nekik kitölteni a
papírokat, beadják és megmondja nekik:
"Egy hét múlva jösztök és kiveszitek az
irataitokat és egy hét múlva
telefonálnak és azt mondják: "Nem adják
ki nekünk." Hát mi nem hittük el, hogy
ez így van, de így volt.
Tehát előítéletesen kezelték őket, és
nem adták ki az irataikat. jogilag ezt
nem tehetik az ő irataik. Nem kell nekem
szócmásként ott lenni. Ez megtörtént.
És akkor nyilván, hogy történnek dolgok,
hogyha ennyire előítéletesen kezd meg
ennyire ki vannak sodrodva a
perifériára. Tehát ha azt látják mindig
előlünk mellőlük, ha azt látják, hogy ha
meglátjuk őket, akkor rögtön
összecsomagoljuk a táskánkat. Igen,
>> pedig 5 mre van, tehát
>> Igen, igen, abszolút. És sőt még azt
mondanám, hogyha arra gondolnék, hogy
roma vér folyik valakinek az erébe,
a nevel neveltetéstől függetlenül, tehát
amit örököl, például a ritmusérzék,
lehet, hogy örökölhető, vagy a nyelv
érzék,
>> teljes mértékű.
>> És ezek mind olyan pozitív dolgok, én én
személy szerint nem gondolom azt, hogy
valaki a bűnözési hajlamot örököl
örökli. Nem, ez egy teljesen más
történet, és az bárki örökölhet. Tehát
van egy örökletes része is az
antiszociális személyiségzavarnak, amibe
ne menjünk most bele, de ez nem ez nem
bőrszíntől és nem fajtol.
Az egyik híres evangéliátor egyébként
antiszociális.
>> Hüm,
>> és megtanulta az antiszocialitását
kontrollálni. David Woods.
>> Ühüm.
>> David Wood.
>> David Wood. vagy vagyis, hogy hogy
hajlamos a a a bűnözésre, vagy vagy volt
valami múltja, és és azt
>> hát teljesen antiszociális
ö az azt jelenti, hogy érzelmei
nincsenek jelent
>> és emiatt
>> tehát ez a pszichopátia.
>> Ez a pszichopátia. Igen, a pszichopátia.
És nem bántotta őt senki. öldöntötte,
hogy aki a társadalom törvényeinek meg
egy adott ponton elcsúszol ezzel, aki a
társadalom törvényeinek megfelel
igazából egy buta báb,
és akkor vett egy kalapácsot, és az
apját, aki soha életében meg nem ütötte,
jól megkalapált azzal a kalapáccsal, azt
megölte. Egyébként azt is akarta, meg
akarta ölni az apját, aki sose bántotta.
Utána felhívta az anyjá, megmondta, hogy
megölte az apját.
Különváltan éltek. Az édesanyja
utánament, ahol jelenleg volt. Hívták a
rendőrséget, hívták a mentőt, és őt
elítélték, és börtönben volt. Börtönben
van egy megtérés. Az is egy nagyon
érdekes történet, hogy hogyan, mert
igazából ilyen nagyon büszkén áll neki
ennek az egész történetnek. És onnan
kezdve teljesen tudatosan próbálja az
érzelmeit gondolatok mentén
behelyettesíteni.
Két fogyatékos kisfia volt. Öt öt fia
született. Két fogyatékos gyerek beteg
gyereke egy ilyen izomsorvadásos,
genetikai izomsorvadásos betegsége volt.
És hát lélegeztetőgépeken voltak.
kikapcsolt a lélegeztetőgép, és majdnem
meghalt az egyik kisfi. A felesége
élesztette, kétségbeesetten, és ő a
zajtókeretben úgy imádkozott, hogy uram,
ha meg kell halni a gyereknek, ne akkor,
amikor az anyja kapcsoltak, akime
megbolondul,
hanem én legyek a hibásinkka.
>> Ühüm.
>> Mert én meg elviselek bármit.
>> Hm.
>> Tehát ennyire De ő ezt így
racionálisan veszi át az empátiát. Hm.
>> Teljesen.
>> Visszatérve a mi témánkra, ez amúgy
nagyon érdekes, és majd a kamerák mögött
még kérdezek egy pár dolgot, de az egyik
dolog, ami így felmerült bennem, hogy
vannak olyan, én hallottam olyan
eseteket, amikor tudatosan titkolták a
gyermek elől, hogy ő örökbe van fogadva.
Erről mi a véleményed? Hát ez egy
borzasztó melléfogás,
merthogy képzeljük el azt, hogy
tény az, hogy egy örökbefogadott
gyermeknek a az identitása összetett,
mertogy ugye van egy egy olyan család,
ami a genetikai alapot adta, meg az
életnek a kezdetét adta,
és ott vannak emberek, és ott vannak
történetek, és utána rátevődik az
örökbefogadó szülőnek nek az identitása.
Az örökbefogadó szülő az esetek 90%-ában
aranyos, felelős emberek, akik mindig
betartják a szavokat.
>> 90%
>> Igen.
>> Jó, de erre visszatérünk mindjárt. Igen,
[nevetés]
>> igen.
És de ez ez egy saccolt százalék, tehát
én most nagyon aranyos voltam igazából.
>> Igen. Igen. Szóval igen, visszatérünk.
Igen.
>> És és megtudja, amikor az identitásának
a krízise forr, és amikor több forráshoz
hozzáfér, és hirtelen látja, hogy
valamikor később van kiállítva a
születési bizonyítványa,
>> és akkor utána néz, hogy miért,
és akkor rájön, hogy ezek a nagyon jó
emberek végighazudták az életét, és ott
dől össze minden. Hm.
>> És ott veszítik el a hitelességüket, és
ott utasítja el őket a gyerek. És
valamilyenképpen, ha ha átállunk az ő
oldalára, és azon gondolkodunk, hogy
mindent, amit tudtam az életemről, az
egy hazugság, amit te mondtál nekem,
>> Ühüm.
>> Akkor vajon hogyan tudna visszamenni?
Tehát ez egy dráma, amit megél utána a
gyermek is, és a szülő is.
>> Tehát ezek
>> ezek drámák.
>> De te is találkoztál ilyen esettel,
>> nem? személyesen, de hallottam róla.
Igen.
>> Ühüm.
>> Tehát ilyen otthonról,
>> tehát gyakorlatilag a jó szándéka a
szülőnek, hogy megóvja egy traumától a
gyermeket,
>> de nem óvja meg egy traumától. A
traumától úgy óvom meg, hogyha értelmet
adunk annak, ami vele történt. Tehát te
kezdettől fogva Anna az én lányom
voltál,
nem tudtalak megszülni, máshova
születtél. Tehát nem elhagytak, nem
valami más történt.
Ennek így kellett történnie.
Más megoldás történt, más forgatókönyv
van.
Mi így vagyunk egymáséi, mármint úgy,
mint család.
Az, hogy eltitkolok valamit, az soha nem
egy megvédés. Ezt nem értjük. És
igazából az a kérdés, ezért mondom, hogy
amikor ezeket érezzük, visszatérve, mert
azt hiszem, hogy nem válaszoltam végül
meg azt, hogy mi történik, amikor
rájövök, hogy zsarolom a gyermekemet.
Tehát pontosan ez van, hogy tartsak
önvizsgálatot, hogy mi történik bennem,
miért van nekem erre szükségem, illetve
tudatosan változtassak ezen a mi van
bennem, mitől félek,
mi az, ami rettegésben tart, hogy nem
mondom el, mert az nem a gyerekről szól,
hanem rólam,
hogy miért nem mondom el neki az igazat,
és segítséget kell ilyenkor kérni,
merthogy kevesebbe kerül, mint egy
dráma. Visszatérve erre a 10%-hoz, engem
meglepett, nem is tudom, hogy miért,
mert de de egy kicsit kicsit beszélnék
erről, hogy
amikor
olyan szülő jön, akinek nem kéne örökbe
fogadnia, gondolom ez az 10%, vagy
lehet, hogy bárhány százalék,
ilyenkor tehát biztos hallottál eseteket
ilyen ilyenkor mi történik?
Hát amikor nagyon szembetűnően nem kell
szülő legyen,
például
mikor adják már nekem ide ezt a
gyermeket, mert már neki kéne fogjak,
hogy neveljem, majd én kordába tartom és
beleverem a dolgokat. De a társadalom
nem arra nem, nem persze, mert most egy
olyan diszfunkcionális társadalom van,
de én majd és akkor látod, hogy igazából
az ő szükségletét akarja, nem érdekli a
gyerek, nem is foglalkozik azzal, hogy a
gyermek egy egyéniség,
>> de gondolom ilyenkor nem adják oda,
>> ilyenkor nem adnják meg a a papírt, hogy
örökbefogadó szülő legyen. Nem, nem
nyilvántják örökbefogadható szülőnek, de
vannak olyan helyzetek, amikor teljesen
jó indulatú emberek, jó emberek, az
emberek nagy része jó, társadalom nagy
része nem bűnözik és nem bánt másokat,
de olyan sérülések vannak, olyan sebek
vannak a lelken.
Egy fantasztikus házaspárral dolgoztam
egy adott ponton.
egy ilyen nagyobb kislányt fogadtak
örökbe. Kilenc éves volt a kislány. Ők
nem akartak róma gyereket.
És hát egy nagyobb kislányt kaptak, aki
nem volt róma gyerek. Kilenc éves voltak
és lány
sorozatos veszítés után döntöttek úgy,
hogy örökbe fogadnak. Nem kívántak
örökbefogadott gyereket. ők azt
szerették volna, hogy két gyerekük
legyen. Ez egy megoldás volt a
problémájukra, de nem lett egy integrált
probléma. Tehát
rendben van, nem lehet, örökbe is
fogadhatok, de ez hogy esik nekem? Hát
ez egy kompromisszum. Na, amíg azt
gondolom, hogy kompromisszum, addig
fogás van rajtam, és addig előfordulhat,
hogy ahányszor arra a gyerekre nézek,
akkor is, hogyha nem tudatosan jut
eszembe tudat alatt, a gondolatok
mennek. Tehát nem tudatosítom, de az van
benne, hogy ez a gyerek a kompromisszum.
És amikor a kompromissszum rájön, hogy ő
a kompromisszum, akkor elkezdi
kipróbálni, hogy vajon mennyire vagyok
én ebbe a családba, és akkor elkezd
mindenféle acting outot. a nem tudom
milyen drága mobiltelefont keresztül
dobni a falon. Mit mondanak a szüleim?
Akkor jó anyagilag ők megengedhették
maguknak. Végül egy jó terápia után
rendbe jöttek a dolgok, de eljöttek és
segítséget kértek. Rengeteget kellett
ezzel a sebbel foglalkozni.
Rengeteget kellett a kislánynak a
sebével foglalkoz. Családterápiának
indult, a fiúkat gyorsan kizártuk.
maradt az anyas kislány,
>> hogy nekik egy fiúk volt, amiután nem
született meg a második gyermek.
>> Ötvesztés, tehát dráma volt abba a
családba, dráma. Feldolgozatlan trauma.
Ez anya, az anya ott hagyta a
munkahelyét. A legjobb anya akart lenni,
nem tudtak egymásra hangolódni.
>> És akkor mi lett végül? Mi
>> végül? Aztán hát a történetnek a
legeslegvége az, hogy
van közöttük egy kis távolság.
Végül a kislány kilépett egy kicsit
abból az identitásból, és megint
megpróbálta, hogy mennyire a szülei,
mikor betöltötte a 18. élettévét a
nevelő anyjának a születésnapján,
elszökött otthonról.
De hogy tartják a kapcsolatot,
támogatják egymást, férhez kis távolság
>> azért hát nem kis távolság, de hogy
férhez ment, tehát hozzáment ahhoz a
fiúhoz, akivel elszökött, gyerekük
született, tehát ő a saját családjában
van. Most nem ezt a jövőt szerették
volna ezek a az egyetemet végzett, jól
kereső emberek. A másik fiúk egy híres
sportoló,
és ez a kislány, ők úgy élik meg, hogy
ez egy
kudarc, de hogy igazából amíg ő a saját
életét tudja élni, addig nem feltétlenül
az az én szempontomból, de hogy ugyanaz
a sérülés jött fel, hogy na
kompromisszum, de ami nem volt jó végül.
Tehát ezzel folyamatosan kell dolgozni.
>> Van-e olyan dolog, amit Anna tanított
meg neked?
azáltal, hogy végigmentél ezen az egész
folyamaton.
>> Most nem tudnék kiemelni egy példát, de
hogy Anna
annával a mi kapcsolatunk nagyon zökkenő
mentes és azt tanulta meg, valahogy ez
volt a stílusom, s ezt tanulta meg, hogy
kommunikálhatunk és bármit elmondhatunk
egymásnak. Tehát azt is, ha tévedek. És
Anna egy hihetetlenül
tiszta tükröt tart elém néha, és nem
finomkodik, mertogy mondom direkt a a
kommunikáció nem sért meg, csak
és te azt gondolod, hogy ez egy jó ötlet
volt,
és akkor tudom, hogy igazából
nemaszkodomik, hanem ezt így fogalmazza
meg. És akkor mondom neki, hogy miért
nem az volt? És akkor azt mondja, hogy
anya, gyere, nézzük meg, gondoljuk át.
Tehát a saját szavaim visszaköszönnek
időnként, és akkor segít, és akkor
elmondja, hogy ő mit látott a
helyzetben.
>> De tényleg, és ahányszor ez előjön, vagy
elmondja, most haragszom rád, vagy most
na
elmondja a véleményét erről vagy arról.
mesélted, hogy édesanyáddal laksz, és és
Anna is egy fiatal hölgy. Egy olyan
környezetben vagytok, ahol mind, tehát
egy ultrafeminin környezetbe. Ez ezt
hogyan
kihívásokat hozz gondolom, hogy a
maszkulinnak nincs jelenléte. Ez ez
hogyan tudod pótolni, vagy hogy hogyan
jelenik meg ebbe a dinamikába?
Mondjuk a pótlás szót azért nem
szeretem, mert ezt soha nem lehet
bemérni, hogy mennyire lehet pótolni.
Tény, hogy ez egy nagyon feminin
környezet.
Nagyon nyíltan beszélünk dolgokról,
arról is beszélünk nagyon nyíltan, hogy
mit gondolok én, hogy miért nem élek
házasságba, tehát miért nem lettem
házas, vagy mi történt? Tehát nincs
tabutéma,
illetve vannak olyan emberek, akik
valamilyen szinten kompenzálnak, és akik
tudják, hogy mi a helyzet, és tudatosan
vállalják ezt. Az egyik a bátyám, akivel
nagyon-nagyon sok időt töltünk, mert
nagyon közel lakunk egymáshoz, és ő
például tudatosan soha nem lép ki a
házból anélkül, hogy meg ne ölelje, vagy
ne beszéljen Annával, vagy ne tehát,
hogy legyen ez a kapcsolat. A másik egy
ö barátunk, aki beleállt ebbe az apa
szerepbe, és ugyanúgy, tehát rászól
Annára, vagy megöleli Annát, vagy
felemeli Annát, vagy ölbe veszi Annát,
vagy tehát ilyen nem ez a hűvös
távolságtartó baráti kapcsolat, ami
általában barátaink gyerekével van, hogy
szia, jaj nagyon aranyos, hanem szépen
megfogják, meg rángatják, meg gyúrják,
meg puszják meg. Tehát ez ilyen sz
mondom, hogy szinte apaalány kapcsolat,
mert hát nem vagyunk 24-ből 24-et, tehát
ez nem mondjuk ráfoghatnánk, hogy olyan,
mint egy elvált szülőség, ahol néha
találkozik a
>> az apukával, és ez is tudatosan van
vállalva, tehát ez is meg van beszélve,
hogy Anna nincs otthon apuka, de vannak
ezek a pótukák, és egyelőre ezzel kell
kezdjünk valamit. És
>> e ez ez tényleg nagy áldás, hogy így a
környezetedben vannak ezek a személyek.
Amúgy Annának a környezetéről
beszélgettünk így egy kicsit az
iskoláról, de a te környezetedet hogyan
fogadta? Most nem a testvéreidre
gondolok, hanem a tágabb környezetre,
hogy hogy megjelent annan az életedben?
Támogató volt úgy többnyire, vagy két
vagy semleges, vagy kételkedő, vagy vagy
hogy milyen? Hát az a környezetem,
amelyik ugye mindenkinek a környezete
ilyen hagymaszerű réteges.
>> Igen.
>> Tehát az a két-három réteg, amelyik
fontos, az támogató volt.
>> És a távolabbiek.
>> Hát az az igazság, hogy ennyire nem
foglalkozom ezzel a történettel. Tehát
mindenki, akivel találkozol az utcán,
azt mondja, hogy jaj, de aranyos, de
utána nem tudod, hogy igazából mi
történik, amikor bemennek a lakásba,
miről beszélnek.
>> Tehát többnyire akkor felületesen
pozitív. felületesen pozitív. Igen, ezt
így megfogalmazhatjuk. De amúgy is én
ezt a világnézetet tanítom Annának.
Véleménye mindenkinek van.
Az ami számunkra fontos, az az, aki hoz
be valamit az asztalra, akinél ott
tudlak hagyni, hogyha a Bukaresbe el
kell utaznom munka ügybe.
Na, azok fontosak, azok elmondhatják a
véleményüket. A többiek,
tisztelettel meghallgatom, nem érdekel.
Hogyha visszanézel erre az időszakra,
van-e valami, amit másképp csinálnál?
>> Sokkal lazább lennék,
és ezt a másik folyamatos sokkal
lazábban kezelem.
>> Hm.
>> Sokkal lazább lennék. Amit nem sajnálok
belőle és meg akarom tartani, ez a
folytonos analízis. Tehát, hogy én hogy
érzem magam a folyamatba, hogy érzékelem
a gyermeket.
Lehet, hogy banállításnak tűnik az, amit
mondok, de mindenkinek, aki ezen az úton
el akar indulni, én azt tanácsolom, hogy
a saját gyermekét próbálja megtalálni.
Tehát lehet, hogy fantasztikus az a
gyermek, de ha úgy érzem, hogy
veszélyezve érzem magam, vagy nem vagyok
én önmagam, vagy ő nem önmaga, vagy
valami történik, vagy valami nem nincs
meg a kémia, akkor nem az én gyermekem
lehet. És ezt nem bűntudattal kell
kezelni, mert ezek a gyermekek nem
selejtek, és nem is áró, akit ki kell
szuperálni a piacon. Neki meg kell
találni azt a szülőt, aki ráhangolódik,
és nekem meg kell találni azt a
gyereket, akire rá tudok hangolódni,
és ő rám, mert
kell szeressük egymást.
Onnan kezdve már kell, tudom, hogy ezt
azt mondják, hogy semmi se kell, de ez
kell.
Igen. A szeretet az egy az egy ez egy
nagyon komplex dolog, mert a magyar
nyelvben egy szavunk van rá.
Azt mondjuk, hogy szeretet, de közben a
vágyat is összetévesztük a szeretettel.
>> Ühüm.
>> És a szeretet számomra nem egy érzelem.
>> Nem, nem az, hogy valami pozitív dolgot
érzek a másik személy iránt.
>> A szeretet az egy szolgálat. A szeretet
az egy munka, a másik személynek a
megismerése. Benne van az, hogy kell
ismernem a másik személyt, időt töltök
vele, áldozatot hozok. Nincs
szeretetkapcsolat ott, ahol csak
érzelmek vannak és felületes
kapcsolódás.
>> Igen. Igen. Mondjuk én nem szolgálatnak
fogalmaznám meg, de nem azért nem
korrigálni akarom, hanem azt mondom,
hogy mindenki találja meg azt a szót,
amit neki kell. A szeretet az az, amikor
akkor is húzok vele, amikor haragszom
rá.
>> A szeretet az cselekedet.
Éigaz. Tehát akkor is szeretem és akkor
is mellette vagyok, amikor semmi kedvem
hozzá, meg amikor ellenemre tett meg,
amikor fegyelmezetlen volt, meg amikor
tehát
és a barátaimat, és akkor is szeretem,
amikor tévedett. Ne ne ne értsük félre a
dolgokat. Nem a cselekedetét szeretem,
az embert szeretem. Tehát őt kihúzom
abból a rossz cselekedetből is, amit
vétett. Ez a szeretet. Nem az, hogy
letagadom, nem is tette, vagy nem is így
akar. Szerintem ez nem szeretet, amikor
nem fogadom el őt mindenestől. Ez nem
szeretet. Az a szeretet, amikor tudom,
hogy hú, de beletrafált,
de mégis én itt vagyok melletted. Én
veled húzok. Baráttal, gyerekkel,
testvérrel,
élettárssal.
összegyűjtöttem egy pár kérdést a
hallgatóktól, és az egyiket szeretném
feltenni neked most így nem szó szerint
fogom feltenni, de az egyik ismerősöm
kérdezte, hogy
ő konkrétan ismer egy olyan családot,
ahol három roma gyereket örökbe
fogadtak, ketten meglopták a szüleiket,
és az egyikük börtönbe került utána.
Ez nyilván ráerősít arra a
sztereotípiára, amit próbálunk
feloldani. De itt mit mit mondanál akkor
ebbe a helyzetbe?
Én nem erre a helyzetre szeretnék
reagálni, pontosan azért, mert nem
tudom, hogy mi történt abba a családba.
De ha példákkal élünk, akkor azt
szeretném megkérdezni, hogy vajon több
rómagyerek árt-e a szüleinek,
mint magyar, román, angol, tehát
statisztikailag
többen bántják a szüleiket.
Van-e egy olyan statisztika, ami
bemutatja, hogy különösen
örökbefogadódás
esetén úgy gondolják, hogy ez egy
aranybánya, és akkor ezt kihasználják.
Sok válasz lehetséges. Én
beszéltünk ezekről az önbeteljesítő
jóslatokról. Tehát nagyon-nagyon
sokszor, hogyha
ö azt képzeljük, hogy
apropó azt, amit mondtál, tehát
életemet és véremet áldoztam ezért a
gyermekért, és teljesen hálátlan, a
végén lehet, hogy hálátlan lesz.
Amikor azt érzi a gyermek, hogy csak egy
pó a hátamon, akkor lehet, hogy egy
adott ponton egy pó lesz a hátamon,
amikor azt látja, hogy egy ilyen keserű
megadással vigyázok rá, mert ez az a
kiút, amit
találtam az életemre, mert valahol
megfeneklett, akkor néha tényleg azzá is
válik.
Én állítom, hogy akármilyen származása
van egy gyereknek,
hogyha hát mondjuk ki bátran, bántalmazó
környezetben nő fel, és ezalatt nem csak
azt értem, hogy megverik a gyereket,
hanem azt, hogy nem érzi azt, hogy
szeretik, hogy nem érzi azt, hogy ő
érték,
hogy nem érzi azt, hogy az ő élete, az
egyénisége, a személyisége fontos, akkor
úgy is fog élni, mintogyha tehát ha szem
Szemétnek tekintem szemétként fog élni.
Nagyon sok esetben,
azt hiszem, talán csak súrolom, mert ez
egy kicsit a moralitás
határán van. Amikor mind a három
gyerekem
rossz utra, akkor lehet, hogy el kéne
azzal foglalkozak, hogy milyen szülő
voltam.
>> Ez egy ez egy nagyon jó ér volt. Ez egy
nagyon jó ér volt. Lassan a végére érünk
a műsornak. Én egy utolsó kérdést tennék
fel, hogy mit üzennél azoknak a
potenciális jövőbeli szülőknek, akik
most azon gondolkoznak, hogy örökbe
fogadjanak? Mivel bátorítanád? Megéri
örökbe fogadni?
>> Nekem mindenképpen. Én újra csinálom.
Szerintem jól érdemes csinálni,
mint minden mást.
Ö ez a gyerekszülőkapcsolat,
a párkapcsolat, ezek olyan alapvető
kapcsolatok, hogy itt nagyon érdemes
mindenre nagyon odafigyelni és nagyon ér
nagy értékként kezelni. Tehát hogyha
sérülékenységi pontjaim vannak, akkor
érdemes ezekkel foglalkozni. Ha örökbe
szeretnék fogadni, akkor nagyon jó lenne
tisztázni magamban, hogy igazából mit
szeretnék.
hogyha csak kompenzálok vagy valam sincs
gond, csak akkor ezt oldjam fel. És
amikor úgy gondolom, hogy nincs
különbség a természetes gyermek és az
örökbefogadott gyermek között az én
szívemben, akkor répek erre az útra.
>> Tehát ha felteszem azt a kérdést, hogy
miért akarok örökbe fogadni, akkor mi a
helyes válasz? Hát ha ha azért akarok
örökbe fogadni, mert nincs saját
gyermekem,
akkor talán dolgozzak még egy kicsit
magamon.
>> Ez egy helytelen válasz. Akkor mondj egy
helyes választ.
>> A helyes válasz az az, hogy gyereket
szeretnék.
Jó, de ezt nem te szülöd. Persze,
örökbefogadóm.
Valaki szülővé úgy válhat, hogy megszüli
a gyerekét, vagy örökbe fogadja,
>> amikor már ezen túl nincsen a miért
választ. Talán az akkora helyes válasz,
amikor már nem tudod megmondani, hogy
miért vágysz a gyermekre. Hát azért,
mert vágyak.
>> Azért, mert gyereket szeretnék. Mit
szeret? Gyereket szeretnék, gyereket.
Úgy-úgy van. Gyereket.
Persze nem megyünk át tudathasadásba.
Tudom, hogy ez egy örökbefogadott
gyermek és tudom, hogy hogy ennek megvan
a specificitása. Ezt nem kell tagadni
és az se baj, hogyha jönnek fel
fájdalmak, vagy bármi. Mindent kezelni
kell. Tehát nem nem egy fáj egy fájó
lélekkel belemenni és mint megoldás,
mint kompromisszum. Tehát ezeket oldjam
fel először, és akkor utána mehet, ha
tényleg a gyerekre vágyom,
amíg a saját gyerekre vágyom,
amíg az örökbe fogadott gyermek nem a
saját gyermek,
addig én nem mennék ebbe bele.
>> Igen.
Nagyon köszönöm neked, hogy
beszélgettünk ezekről a témákról. Néha a
Galuska ott volt a torkomban, nem tudom
mennyire láttad rajtam. Főleg az egyik
gondolat, amit nagyon megérintett, az
az, hogy
bár te nem vagy az én biológiai
gyermekem, én a te anyád vagyok, hogy ez
ez nem oda-vissza történik, nem
szimmetrikus ez a kapcsolat ilyen
szempontból, de én anya lettem. És hogy
ezt tudjad, hogy én anya lettem, és én
én valódi anya vagyok. Ilyen szempontból
nem a biológiai édesanyád vagyok, hanem
egy egy valódi anya, aki aki itt vagyok
melletted, és te nem mész sehova.
>> Így igaz. De ezt ki kell mondani, és
többször ki kell mondani, pont ugyanúgy,
mint azt, hogy milyen ügyes és milyen
fantasztikus. Egyébként Annának az egyik
kedvenc kérdése az az, hogy anya,
elmondod megint, hogy mi volt a legjobb
döntés az életedből?
És hát tudjuk, hogy miért akarja ezt,
ugye? [nevetés]
>> Mert a válasz erre az, hogy te.
>> Te
>> köszönöm szépen, Idik, hogy itt voltál.
>> Én is köszönöm.
[zene]